et on est moins
on est quand même promo
avec
à leurs frais
avec le grand frère tu sais tu entends
c'est souvent papa yannick
un moment c'était tonton yannick est
plus dans quelques temps ça va être papy
année
ici c'est le village des to die c'est là
que j'ai grandi et les premières années
où j'habite et si on allait chercher de
l'eau en bas je suis le patriarche de ce
qui était un village et maintenant c'est
un des quartiers diang des
responsabilités c'est une sorte de mère
de ce quartiers ce à tous les niveaux
c'est à dire mais savoir que tu fais
déjà que tu es déjà là présent tu
t'occupes des petits je te tue des
anciens j'ai plus de temps en temps pour
les plus jeunes qui c'est une bière de
temps en temps
c'est maman qui a fondé l'école ici elle
était prof de français et puis un jour
là naïma d'aller en ville et puis dans
le jardin l'ami abukar ol a marqué
jardin d'enfants on a commencé avec une
douzaine d'enfants et maintenant il ya
400 gamins
est-ce que ça va
ça a bien c'était bien les marionnettes
tu as aimé les marionnettes y est ce ta
maginot
ce bâtiment là c'était ma maison
ça c'était notre jardin et tout autour
c'était la brousse
on dit quoi 1
si ça c'était ma chance est venue la
classe
justement ça c'est le ciel devient pas
100 premiers
jours
ça va les enfants
à bien votre avis il travaille bien ok
on vous embête pas longtemps parce que
vous savez que si c'était ma chambre
quand j'étais petit oui c'était ma
chambre donc j'espère que ça va vous
porter chance ok allez bon courage tout
le moins payés y est
allé en tout cas l'air merci merci à
demain les enfants
je suis parti d'ici j'avais 12 ans
j'étais un petit môme je vaux tennis
voilà j'allais suivre mon destin quoi
en fait je suis parti mais 48 ans
revenait de temps en temps et hélas tout
d'un coup j'ai eu comme un appel tu vois
mon destin c'est de protéger voilà la
terre qui aime ma terre qui est la terre
de mes ancêtres
et de la protéger jeunes en faire
quelque chose de cool parce que à mon
âge c'est la transmission qui compte et
la transmission c'est voilà moi je le
fais pour mes enfants je le fais pour
mes petits-enfants
et au moins je leur laisserai ça ça pas
juste un trophée dans une vitrine ou des
souvenirs si on est vraiment ici
aujourd'hui c'est beaucoup grâce à ma
mère enfin l'été aventurière elle est
tombée amoureuse de papa pascal emile
foot à l'époque dans les années fastes
années 50 tomber amoureux d'un du noir
de la ville c'était c'était un projet et
quand on est arrivé ici même ou même
jusqu'à arriver ici mon père il était
pas trop pourquoi il avait l'impression
de que ce retour était plus un échec qu
autre chose alors que moman voyez ça
comme le début de quelque chose donc il
ya eu cette vision puis on a habité ça
ici mon père s'est pris au jeu et papa
lui il bougeait plus il aurait pu venir
avec nous tout le temps où en france aux
états unis qu'en bouger mais il est
toujours resté là parce que son truc
c'était de conserver cet endroit et son
rêve fou c'était que je vienne et pas
seulement que je m'en occupe mais que je
sois là
je pense que j'aurais pas pu venir il ya
trois ans ce n'était pas le moment et
puis là tout d'un coup c'était le moment
mais alors là ça m'a défoncé quoi parce
que parce que je suis trop bien
voilà c'est si je dois être moi c'est
mon destin d'être ici déjà j'étais
considéré comme le chef en devenir donc
quand papa les parties automatiquement
bon bien une grande cérémonie les gens
sont très spirituel il
ya des croyances on demande
l'acceptation des défunts donc il ya
toute une cérémonie ces foires parce que
tu as plein d'anciens tu as des vieux
tonton qui sont là moi j'arrive de
france quand même avec ma culture
française dans bien même j'ai de garder
un petit des appuis ici mais tout d'un
coup tu du rien chef du village
il a fallu que je me remette à apprendre
comprendre au minimum le dialecte local
c'est une vraie responsabilité mais
j'ai un chien bagarreur